my name is Jim Fredrik I'm the
International editor Time magazine and I
recently hosted a panel to kick-off
panel actually for the Davos 2012 annual
meeting in Switzerland and the subject
of the panel was his 20th century style
capitals in failing 21st century society
we put the question over the weight of
the audience and your audience by
two-thirds of the 20th century
capitalism was failing 21st Society for
the five panelists disagree and then we
had a rousing debate by the issues
facing the economic crisis immigration
technology close income inequality and
the jobs disparity education disparity
developing world that there are tons of
jobs to be had but the problem is
education I think that the debate that
we had was was a great one and actually
has shaped and informed many of the
conversations that are happening at the
Davos summit for the rest of this week